you're watching reason live streaming to
you from Los Angeles the following is a
live conversation between the host the
guests and the online audience if you'd
like to participate please leave your
question in the YouTube chat the views
expressed by guests and the audience
members in this discussion do not
necessarily reflect those of reason and
now your host Zach why some more hey
folks thank you for joining this is
you're in here on the ground floor of
our experiment our live stream
experiment and I appreciate it
this is new for me new for a reason it's
just something that I wanted to try
because as video journalists we spend a
lot of time talking to people and kind
of distilling down the essence of what
they have to say but in those
conversations we really uncover a lot of
interesting material and have
interesting conversations and so I just
wanted we just want to share a little
bit of that in a looser format and today
and the rest of this week I'm gonna be
hosting it but we're hopeful that if
this experiment works out well that
other recent staffers will come on and
we'll have a sort of rotating host in
this seat so if you do like what you see
here today and the rest of this week
please let us know you can tell us in
the comments section you can email us
the the email we're using for this
program is questions at recent comm and
today in this very first livestream
we're gonna be talking to Josiah Zehner
who runs a company called the Odin that
sells do-it-yourself crispr kits that
allow you to genetically modify
organisms from the comfort of your own
home so we're gonna get to Josiah in
just a minute is a really interesting
guy and I think you're going to enjoy
this conversation and but do know that
this is a participant participatory
forum that's
part of what I'm trying to create here
is a space where people who are
interested in these topics can come in
and and ask questions and and
participate in the conversation so we
will be checking the chat and yes a
you're hearing Josiah's daughter she's
she's sick so you might hear some some
baby noises in the background but you
know that's that's the beauty of live
video we take life as it comes so we
will get started with your site in just
a second I one thing I do want to let
you know is I mentioned before we're
going to be doing one of these every day
this week at various times and tomorrow
we're going to be talking to Lenore scan
Daisy about how to raise a kid and give
them maximum freedom in this world that
seems to point in the other direction
but if you want to be notified about
these videos or many of the other
documentaries and interviews that we've
put up on our Channel please be sure to
subscribe and press that little
notification bell to get the
notifications when we go live so without
further adieu I'm gonna play a little
clip from the first documentary short I
did on Josiah and his company just I
think it's going to give you a sense of
the Odin his company and Josiah and kind
of where he's coming from and then we
will get right into the conversation so
take a look at this suffering needlessly
because all these committees and all
these rules and what happens if people
just start saying like [ __ ] you I'm
gonna do it anyway and what if people
start getting cured
you
okay so here we are with Josiah he is a
self-described bio hacker hello Josiah
hey what's up Zach good to see you again
fit me in the window here yeah look
looking good okay so we we made that
video back in June of 2016 and your
company was just kind of getting started
at that point now a couple years later
could you just tell us what has changed
since then have you seen growth have you
seen have you expanded your product line
where is the Oden at at this point oh
yeah man that was really cool I remember
when you first came there I look a
little uh you know rough cuz I was
working all the time in my garage
packing up these kids trying to get my
startup going since then things have
been going great the company is you know
kicking butt we're growing really fast
we're about to move into a new space in
Oakland yeah people are buying these
kits people are interested in genetic
engineering and synthetic biology and
CRISPR and I think that's amazing and
could you and could you let us know just
for people who are new to this area what
the overview you know CRISPR is
basically a gene editing mechanism could
you just give kind of the dummies
version of what CRISPR is and why it's
important yeah so CRISPR is important
it's this new genetic engineering
technology that actually allows people
to edit genomes easier than we could
ever do before and what this allows is
it allows you know greater accessibility
for not only researchers but also people
who are trying to do the stuff in their
home or you know and it's some embryos
and a lot of people in the chat are
already asking about designer babies and
we're gonna talk about that in a little
bit given the news out of China the
recent news out of China I know you have
some thoughts on that but first I want
to get
just this overview a little bit and and
one thing I want to ask is just you know
what are people actually making with
these kits that you're selling you know
out of your garage yeah so a lot of our
kits are educational so you know genetic
engineering and CRISPR and things like
that it's a lot like programming right
so it's these kits what they do is they
essentially teach people to program
genetically so they're not necessarily
meant to allow people to do you know
greater and cooler stuff though you can
but people have to learn to do that
stuff a lot of people right now are
really interested in human genetic
engineering especially in the bio hacker
community there are a lot of people who
have been you know self experimenting
and trying crazy stuff in that area and
I think that's gonna blow up the oden
our company we actually started selling
kits that allow people to learn how to
do animal genetic engineering with frogs
and you know that's getting really big
so people are starting to move more
towards things that can contribute
directly to science and medicine right
now which is crazy it blows my mind yes
so talk about that aspect of your entire
project because this is really about
democratizing science in a way you're
trying to you know it's a lot of these
this is cutting-edge science and a lot
of it for decades has been locked up in
institutions university laboratories
government laboratories you yourself
worked for NASA at one point so give me
a little bit of that philosophy that is
driving you right now yeah I mean so I
think all my philosophy kinda stems from
you know the computer hacker movement I
grew up in you know 90's computer hacker
movement and it was all about making
things accessible all about like people
being able to program and create
whatever they want to create and that
just led to an explode
and you know computer programming
computer tech and even nowadays there
are so many resources that have just
expanded off that like github and all
these places where you know Stack
Overflow where people can get access to
code get access to answers on how to do
these things and that's just amazing and
computers were once just in universities
they were once something that nobody
could afford and when people said well
we should make computers accessible to
everybody people kind of laughed and
they were like what is somebody gonna do
with the computer you know I'm like
these are for you know solving equations
to shoot missiles and stuff so then you
eventually figured out how to do stuff
and now you know we use them so much and
I think the same thing can happen with
genetic engineering right like this
technology is so powerful it's probably
one of the most powerful technologies we
know of right and like just keeping it
in the hands of a few people it just
doesn't make any sense to me right it
doesn't make any sense at all like how
can we get this into the most hands
possible so it can help the most people
possible and so you've been working to
do that and you've already gotten it in
lots of hands and someone in the
comments section is asking Turtles with
bombs has anyone done anything exciting
with homemade CRISPR yet has anybody
done anything exciting with homemade
CRISPR um I don't know from as far as I
know it's still in its infancy so I
don't think anything anybody's done it
anything too crazy but you know people
are learning it's like the early days of
people having computers you know you
can't people what people are doing is
basically the equivalent of writing
basic computer programs that do hello
world or whatever something like that
and it's starting to progress beyond
that point but it all takes time right
like you have to understand that like
the personal computer from the time that
was invented until we had you know all
the programs and everything we we could
use it took years and it's the same
thing with this my company we just
really started you know in a 2000
tene so it's uh it's been a very short
period of time and to see the growth is
crazy people are super interested I'm
excited about what people are going to
create and let me play another clip from
one of our other documentaries we made
where you know you went from you you
start selling kits that made things like
glowing beer and this glowing beer well
it made it genetically modified yeast to
make the yeast glow and then people
could make glowing beer and I'm gonna
throw up some images of that just right
now because like biohackers and people
doing science at home is so new there's
really not much regulation at the moment
people have a lot of freedom to do some
people are even getting mad academics
and people working in universities
because they have institutional
guidelines that they have to follow so
the government doesn't impose certain
guidelines on research but the
institution the university imposes
guidelines on those researchers then
which if you're working in your garage
or your institution is basically you and
maybe your friends and stuff like that
so there's no regulation I think that
the government probably in the future
sometime will try to regulate it okay so
have we reached that point yet has the
government tried to regulate the space
or are you still kind of so far ahead of
the curve where the regulators are just
catching up with you
so I think we're pretty far ahead of the
curve but last year I did a couple
experiments to genetically modify myself
to learn about human genetic engineering
and just to see what was possible
because you see these gene therapies
like Lux Aeterna being sold for a
million dollars to treat people cure
genetic form of blindness a million
dollars could you imagine if somebody
came up to you and told you like yeah we
can cure your blindness but it'll cost
you a million dollars like and your
insurance won't cover it that would be
crazy
so I want to understand like like how
difficult is it actually to do human
genetic engineering because obviously
I'd never died before
so the only person I had
experiment don was myself and didn't
want to experiment on my brother even
though he's a little crazy and I was
actually successful and a couple
different techniques and right after
that not long maybe like a month or two
the FDA immediately put out a notice
that said like any use of CRISPR is
genetic engineering genetic modification
gene therapy technology and will
immediately be regulated it was pretty
crazy what did you do to yourself so I
did a couple experiments one was to take
the same jellyfish gene from the yeast
and put that in my body right the other
was basically you made our psyche glow
is that is that what happened it didn't
it like I couldn't see it visually with
my eyes but that was the goal but I was
able to detect the you know the proteins
of DNA the RNA inside my cells so the
goal would be you'd have to infect a
large number cells something like that
though is definitely possible they do it
in you know animals all the time so it
was just seeing like how to apply it to
humans like how different is this then
what they talked about in papers and
academia and things like that and the
other was I injected myself with a
myostatin knockout CRISPR experiments
okay I want to talk more about that in
just a second but I do have a clip of
that moment that I want everyone to
enjoy
this will modify my muscle G genes to
give me bigger muscles
Oh didn't actually hurt that much
Oh first a lot more going in alright
there we go okay so how did it work out
oh man I don't know whatever I can see
that if I should feel embarrassed or so
I did some tests I did biopsy and
there's these tests you can run to check
the DNA sequence inside the cells right
to see if there are any changes in the
DNA bases this happens when the
Cassadine protein cuts the DNA and the
DNA comes back together I saw changes
but I also saw changes in my control
sample which was just my blood my red
blood cells so it wasn't it wasn't
really conclusive
I didn't inject a lot it if you watch
the video you can see or I talked about
like in order to really get a strong
effect you need to inject a lot more DNA
and do multiple injections so usually
when they do gene therapies what they do
is you know they'll do like I know for
one gene therapy that was a prude glide
beer I think they do like 20 injections
or something like that so it would
probably need to be significantly more
that that experiment was kind of like a
proof of concept but also trying to be
provocative because you can make these
gene therapies for hundreds of dollars
and I don't think people understand that
right when a company comes and says
we're selling this for a million dollars
it doesn't cost a million dollars to
manufacture it costs maybe you know a
few thousand dollars that's it
right yeah and and I mean some of this
self experimentation has gotten
it has work to be provocative and get a
lot of press and and you gave some
interviews after a gentleman I believe
injected some sort of herpes vex
homemade herpes vaccine and himself at a
conference and and you said you told the
Atlantic there's no doubt in my mind
that somebody is going to end up hurt
eventually do you still feel that way
are you starting to have second thoughts
about where this is all going you know I
mean so when I did these experiments you
know I did my PhD and all these things
and I you know worked with animals and
worked with you know million cell code
all these things before I did these
experiments and you know coding your own
DNA and and you know figuring out
protocols how to inject I spent a lot of
time working on that like a year and a
half testing a bunch of different
techniques on myself and measuring the
DNA and and RNA and things in my cells I
didn't expect things to happen so fast
and even with the genetic modification
of these embryos whether it's true or
not like think things are moving way
faster than I expected and that kind of
scares me right like I mean because I
just didn't when you don't anticipate
something when it's so new when it's so
something outside your comfort zone it
scares you a little bit but I also think
there's a lot of excitement in that fear
yeah and yes since you brought it up
let's get into the what seems to have
been a CRISPR modified human embryo in
China of two twin girls that were
actually given birth to so this is the
first if if true this is the these are
the first CRISPR modified human beings
and of course since it's 2018 the
scientists who did it made a youtube
video about it and here's a clip from
his YouTube video RTG so Davi may be the
only available we do he'll I
Herbert disease and prevent a left hand
suffering we hope you have the mercy for
them their parents don't want a develop
a just a child a won't suffer from a
disease with medicine cannot prevent
gene surgery is and should remain a
technology for hearing enhancing IQ or
selecting higher or eye color is not
what a loving purple does that should be
banned understand my work will be
controversial but I believe family need
this technology and I'm willing to take
the criticism the thing okay so that was
I'm not sure to pronounce his name he's
genku i apologize for butchering your
name but he he's making the case here
that what he's done what he claims to
have done is made these young these baby
girls resistant to HIV so and he is
framing it as an ethical imperative
especially in China where having AIDS
carries a special stigma with it so
what's your reaction to that and as
someone who pays close attention to the
science here how much do we know about
how real this is
yeah you know so I'm sure you know and
you saw on Twitter and the news media
everybody freak has freaked out about it
and I guess that's kind of
understandable because this is just
totally crazy right you can imagine the
first time ever a human being gets
genetically modified and born and it was
outside all mainstream right this guy
dr. John ku
hee hee essentially he said he paid for
it himself in the talk he gave who knows
if that's true or not or how much he
paid for himself but he essentially you
know was a biohacker he working
completely outside the system right not
trying to do it in any institution not
trying to do it with any company or
anything like that and it it it was just
crazy right I think a lot of people are
freaked out because like what everybody
expected when they did IVF and like one
of the first IVF babies was born you
know they have like documentary crews
following these people around and we're
like oh my gosh this is you know so
awesome it's such a point in history and
you know the media had access to all
these people and this time just some guy
that people you know he has a PhD and he
studied uh you know science and all the
stuff before but like he's no name
technically in academia and in academia
you're not allowed to be a no name and
do cool and interesting stuff it just
you don't get the funding right it
doesn't happen but discount basically he
he jumped the line he jumped to the
front of the queue they're totally right
yeah like because you know what would
happen normally in the u.s. a bunch of
scientists would write grants and apply
to the FDA and apply to the government
and say we want to do this experiment
and the FDA would choose one of these
universities or companies and say
alright you get to be the first one who
does this and it's so political and it's
so full of [ __ ] right and he totally
jumped that line and not only that he's
not Western right and that's just crazy
and I think that that's blowing people's
minds that he's not from the Western
world right Europe or the US or any
place like that he's from China and
that's what people are like you know
they're scared of that yeah and that's
that's something that we're going seems
like we're gonna have to contend with
because in a way China seems like
not the Wild West but I guess the wild
East like they are just like it's not
gonna be so on some level it was not
surprising to me that this came out of
China and that there are going to be
more things like that coming out of that
country so given that that's likely you
know what's the reaction on our salon in
the United States and and in Western
countries when you've got another
country that's going to possibly just be
going full steam ahead with this yeah I
know Zach the crazy thing is that like
we're scared because we're like oh my
gosh like the US has always been you
know the scientific soup URI you know
like super power and we've always done
everything first right like we've always
been behind so much of science and as we
start to lose this you know to other
countries to China because of our
regulations holding people back because
of our you know religiosity where we
think things are so sacred it's gonna
prevent us from you know being doing all
these cutting-edge things and everybody
else is going to you know accomplish
them first so the thing about this
experiment is that you know as far as I
can tell you I did a PhD in protein
biochemistry biophysics so I can look at
the DNA and amino acid sequences of the
ccr5 proteins that he engineered and I
can see you know tell if it would have a
similar effect to the ccr5 Delta 32
which is the naturally occurring you
know HIV resistant gene mutation and as
far as I can tell even modeling these
proteins on a structural level it looks
like that they should all work so like
it looks like he should be successful if
the data that he presented is true and
real like
looks like he actually you know did was
successful and that's you crazy but
there's been a lot of pushback from the
scientific community saying there's a
there are things that don't look like
they quite make sense and that that we I
mean obviously we don't know what the
long-term effects of this are going to
be but are the criticisms out there of
what he's done
well-founded from your perspective and I
mean just on the scientific level we can
get to the ethics in just a second
no I mean I think we do understand the
long-term effects though and that's the
crazy thing right it this didn't happen
in a bubble and I think the problem is a
lot of people are looking at it like
that people are saying this person did
this experiment and it was in a bubble
but it wasn't so not only where
experiments done on mice and monkeys and
they them tested like behaviorally and
everything but other researchers have
used this CRISPR on the same exact place
on the same exact gene and found that it
didn't have any of these off-target
effects so it seemed like what he was
doing was he was going for some you know
low-hanging fruit so to speak some gene
that was already really well studied
just so I can sorry just to interject
for a second the off target effects just
means basically unintended consequences
and you're saying that as far as you can
tell none show up in the genome at this
point is that basically your read of the
situation and what he so what they did
was they did genome sequencing on the
embryo after fertilization after CRISPR
then they did genome sequencing three
times while the embryo was inside the
mother and then they did three times
then they did genome sequencing once it
was born on the cord blood another you
know threefold genome sequencing and
they
claimed they found no off-target effects
obviously you know nobody's seen the
data for this but if this person is
presenting the data we have to take it
at you know face value what they present
so they looked at all these things
extensively probably the most gene
sequenced human beings to ever exist
were these babies being born and they
could find nothing nothing abnormal in
them there so there are obviously a lot
of ethical implications here and people
are asking about it in the comments well
okay one person here says Mike musk part
says why would it be wrong to have
designer babies as far as I can tell
it's perfectly moral to want your
children to have desirable traits so
we're talking about not just taking out
you know or creating a sort of immunity
to HIV or taking out the Parkinson's
gene or whatever I guess we're talking
about cosmetic changes eye color IQ
Heights these sorts of things what's
your take on that debate so you know
first we can look at what surveys have
shown right so a bunch of people have
done surveys on genetic modification
embryo genetic modification and in the
the latest survey a 11% of people only
11% of people were against gene
modification of an embryo to prevent a
disease or prevent suffering in some way
right only 11% were against we're
talking you know not scientists just
general population everybody and then
when you talk about enhancement that
number goes up a bit it's more like 30%
are Gantz and 30% are far for and like
40% are uncertain but my question
basically is is how do you define an
enhancement versus a disease right so if
if you say well is it can it be
considered a disease to be of short
stature right so if you're like
three-foot-tall is that considered a
disease most people would probably say
you know yeah like that that's something
that we could treat but then you say
well what about 3.6 inches
what about 4 foot what about 4 or 6
inches what about 5 foot right there's
no clear way to draw a line between
disease and enhancement because it's
it's all part of the human experience
and so because there's no line to draw I
think instead of focusing on should we
do this or shouldn't we do this we
should be figuring out like how do we
make this accessible to people right
right like we're trying to stop
something that we can't stop we're
trying to control something that we
can't control you can't control DNA
right like drug sniffing dogs you you
can have things that smell drugs like
DNA is everywhere you can't have dogs
that sniff DNA you could send DNA on a
piece of paper in an envelope to
somebody and they could purify it from
that like scientists do this all the
time right so it's like an
uncontrollable type of drug and like
what are you gonna do stop trying to
control it
instead let's figure out how to go
forward with it properly so everybody
gets access to it like that's the big
deal to me okay so yeah this is kind of
the broader like transhumanist question
which is if these things are inevitable
is you seem to believe they are I guess
that means we should just step on the
gas and you know see what happens and
all become supermen or I mean how do you
see this this all playing out you know
what I have no idea I mean I'm sorry let
me ask you another question because one
thing that does worry me a little bit
about it is the prospect of a getting in
under the control of governments so if a
scientist in China has is the first one
to do this to a human being we know what
the Chinese government is like and if we
are starting you know if there's an
ability to one day say enhance
iq is the government going to start kind
of mandating that IQs be enhanced as a
competitive advantage in the global
economy and then are we in a sort of
arms race type situation I mean is this
just fantastical crazy speculative stuff
or is this within the realm of reality
as far as you can tell
well the question is isn't like are
people going to do this the question is
has it already happened and the answer
to that is yes right if you look at
vaccinations it was ruled by I think it
was a supreme court or a court in Boston
Massachusetts that people can be forced
to vaccinate themselves if it is in
regards to the public good right
vaccinations what they do is your body
creates an immune response to these the
things that you inject in and what that
does is that modifies your DNA that
immune response is stored in your DNA so
then for the rest of your life or ten
years or something your body can react
you know immunological II - you know
this disease or whatever is going on and
that is genetic modification force
genetic modification not only that like
you think about how we screen for things
like trisomy 21 and other diseases right
isn't that kind of like you're you're
trying to remove from your population
people who might be less intelligent
right a lot of the you know trisomy 21
things like that cause mental deficits
usually and we we in many countries you
know trying to remove those things from
our population like where as the line
already been passed is my question and I
think it has right we we are already
screening embryos for a number of
diseases when you have children right
they screen the embryo you they can now
purify the fetal blood cells from the
mother's blood
really easily they don't have to do
amniocentesis anymore old school where
they'd like stick a needle into the you
know amniotic fluid no they could just
take draw mother's blood and test the
baby screen the baby right before it's
even born know what's going on like the
stuff is it's already there it's already
happening and to me it's like people
just they they want to close their eyes
to it they don't want to recognize they
don't want to believe it's going on and
instead they're worried about this book
potential boogeyman that we already have
that already exists right and so it's
something more that we have to embrace
it's something more that we have to look
at you know modern medicine is something
that can be beneficial to so many people
and I'm not gonna saying necessarily
that like we should genetically modify
babies or something like that but there
are so many ways you know
pre-implantation genetic diagnosis where
you know you can do IVF and you could
screen you take a few cells out of the
fertilized embryo and screen those right
imagine if everybody had embryos that
you know ten embryos when you want to
get pregnant they said alright here pay
ten thousand dollars what we'll do is
we'll take ten embryos sequence them
will tell you the eye color the
approximate height what diseases they
might be susceptible to and you get to
choose one of those ten embryos like you
get to choose a healthy child like I
don't know what parent wouldn't choose a
healthy child right yeah here wants to
see their child suffer but then as you
said it's difficult maybe impossible to
delineate between what is a health issue
and what is elective you might say and
that will be an ever-evolving question
as the technology advances and people
can more easily make these tweaks does
it make sense to draw a line and say you
know I mean first of all how do you even
get there with humans given the ethical
implications this is a these babies
these embryos that you're experimenting
on are going to become a human being so
how do you ethically say well yes it's
okay to experiment with modifying their
genome using CRISPR yeah that's an
interesting question and it's it was a
strange question in a couple ways
because and I don't it's hard to wrap
your head around for a number of reasons
the first is that like experimenting on
an embryo is experimenting on a human
but having an abortion most people you
know don't consider that a human which
is strange to me you know because it's
like wait can you can you can you hold
both of those ideas in your mind at the
same time and it still makes sense maybe
right because technically you're killing
something before it comes out instead of
like you know something that will come
out the other thing is like embryos and
children have no they have no rights
right as a parent you choose whether to
vaccinate your children if you mind if
vaccinate your children you choose
everything for your child right you
choose whether your child is you know
what school they go to what food they
eat you know so many different things
and it's yeah yeah it's like children
don't get a choice in anything well so
why is that all of a sudden a big deal
why you know I read something on Duke
University website about this and they
were talking about you know the embryo
doesn't consent and that kind of made me
chuckle a little bit because I'm just
like wait when do we ever ask embryos or
children for consent for anything like
when it's like a I don't know well
there's a couple questions coming in
here then one of them is kind of
interesting it's someone asks misra
asks what are the IP implications of
CRISPR if you if I use your kit to
create a new strain of yeast and attempt
to patent it would open or Jennifer dude
Naju just one of the discoverers of
CRISPR have a competing claim so yeah I
mean it there are already major IP
battles going on over CRISPR could you
give us the lay of the land there and
and kind of what your thoughts are on
you know being able to patent something
like CRISPR my company we don't things
we don't try to take away people's
rights or anything like that the patent
landscape for CRISPR so basically CRISPR
existed it was discovered it wasn't
created and then it was patented for use
right so this is a really interesting
thing that happens with biologicals and
that is that biologicals that are
discovered can't be patented but their
use can be patented right so you can
patent the use of CRISPR and humans or
patent the use of CRISPR and in certain
organisms so if you use CRISPR in an
organism to modify it and then sell that
organism on the market you'd probably be
breaking you know the IP packet rights
whether they wanted to enforce that or
not is unknown and there hasn't seemed
there don't seem to be much enforcement
going on right now with these patents
there does seem to be a lot of Licensing
going on though the patent landscape for
CRISPR is insane there are thousands of
patents you know there have been filed
and like multiple people on different
parts of the technologies so it's just
crazy nobody really knows how it's gonna
pan out so it's just I you know in my
opinion go to a country that doesn't
enforce us can make your organism or do
your human labor vagina perhaps someone
else asks dark darks
the Hanged clown asks does CRISPR work
on plants yeah oh yeah I know so CRISPR
works on most every organism not quiet
every organism but it generally so what
CRISPR actually does how it works is
there's this protein called cast 9 that
was found in bacteria and what this
protein does is it cuts your DNA that's
it it just cuts your DNA when it cuts
your DNA your cell initiate a repair
process to repair this DNA now that
repair process is present in many many
different organisms um every organism
especially mammals and on up so when
this repair process happens that's when
you can genetically modify DNA or the
cells because you can trick the cell
into inserting something into the genome
so you can imagine it's it's yeah it's
pretty adaptable across and someone else
here has a kind of a clear more clearly
formulated question of what I was trying
to get at earlier which is this is from
radical Barre question it's clear humans
will be doing CRISPR on babies unless
government cracks down and as you've
already mentioned it's going to be
difficult to crack down eventually how
do we minimize the negative effects
randomized control trials Oh geesh
randomized control trials here's the
problem is really interest and why I
think the FDA is eventually gonna be on
its way out so the FDA is decent at what
it does right so their goal is to allow
people to make medicines the amount of
people help the most amount of people
and get companies money right because if
companies aren't making money off of the
drug discovery process and they're not
gonna keep making drugs it doesn't make
any sense so what happens is you get
these drugs that are trying to treat oh
you know a large group of people it's
not looking for individual outcomes
right which is completely different
thing individual outcomes can't be
clinical trials and a lot of medicine
like gene editing like immunotherapy is
precision it's based on your genome it's
based on who you are right so the
clinical trial model doesn't necessarily
work for this type of thing right it's
so this is why your one reason you're an
advocate of self experimentation not
necessarily an advocate of self
experimentation I'm an advocate of self
experimentation because I haven't found
out a better way to work around these
FBA guns legally right that's the big
part is legally is like I could go and I
could pirate luck sterno which is the
gene therapy that was you know just
approved last year at the end of last
year which cures this inherited form
blindness I could pirate that and make
that for a few thousand dollars and
provide it to people obviously I'm gonna
go to jail for it right and I'm not
gonna inject anybody in their eyeball
either like I'm not down for that yeah
but like it makes this question like how
do we get these individual outcomes to
people right how do we get drugs to
people inexpensively how do we make a
system that can help people except it's
it doesn't require people to invest
hundreds of millions of dollars it
doesn't require five or ten years it
incentivizes getting people healthy and
I don't know yet but it's definitely not
the FDA is there a model of I mean it's
the with the self experimentation I mean
is there any precedent of that working
out well like leading to some sort of
breakthrough or is it always kind of a
scientist just slowly killing himself by
enjoy yourself of toxins you know I mean
self experimentation has been
a you know his a storied history in
science even as recently as you know the
late 90s and 2000's when Barry Marshall
drank he lobe actor pylori he convinced
people that ulcers were caused by
bacteria and not just stomach acid so he
drank it to give himself ulcers and then
took antibiotics to cure it which was
you know crazy and he won a Nobel Prize
for it I'm not saying anything I do is
Nobel prize-worthy probably you know not
for sure but I think getting around all
the regulations that sometimes are put
in place to prevent people from bringing
people treatments is a positive thing
right people always look at biohackers
like or people like me like were dumb
and we're hateful or we're doing things
bad and it all comes from the heart it
all comes from like look I know people
who are dying from these disease I know
people who are suffering like all I'm
trying to do is get these people help
right now and if you can see that if the
FDA can see that if the government can
see that that like all we're trying to
do is get people help maybe we can find
a way forward yeah I mean this is really
a I guess systemic critique the that's
implicit in your project which is like
we need a wee you know these
institutions are important but we also
need a decentralized science because
that's a different way for discoveries
to be made and just to kind of buttress
your point about the FDA and some of the
obstacles they throw up I want to play
one more clip here and then we'll close
out with a few more audience questions
and this is from a time that the FDA
kind of you you had to get on the phone
with the FDA so let's take a look at
that a kit allowing anyone to make yeast
fluorescent by inserting a gene from a
jellyfish
if the CRISPR kit is akin to an
open-ended programming tool for advanced
users the yeast kit is more like a ready
to use program you download from the app
store consumers don't necessarily want
to build
from scratch the majority of people just
want to use it I just want to be able to
use this to you know make a new organism
several breweries began to put the yeast
app to use right away brewing
fluorescent beer one even offered to
partner with them to create a special
blend when a local reporter began
writing up a story about the partnership
word reached the Food and Drug
Administration which gave zainer a call
and informed him he was selling an
unapproved food additive just for your
background information anything that
imports colors the food is considered a
color additive and under the federal
Food Drug and Cosmetic Act color
additives need to have pre-market
approval by FDA they can't technically
regulate our kits because our kits
aren't food they can only really
regulate the way we market our kits we
can tell people you can get these kits
and use them to engineer yeast and
wouldn't it be cool if someday you could
use engineer used to brew right
hypothetically in another okay so it's
kind of amusing to me that you
genetically modified this yeast to make
it glow and then FDA is like well
technically that's a color additive like
that's their concern about this but how
did that all work out first of all so
what we did it was interesting because
you know to submit these things to the
FDA and get approval is you know pretty
ridiculous I mean the the experiments
that people do or submit to the FDA
sometimes they're just a joke it's like
we ran it through this database to see
if there were it matched any known
toxins we ran it through this database
to see if it matched any known allergens
and stuff like that we did the same
thing but that wasn't necessarily a
concern because this molecule GFP you
can literally find videos and clips
online of like whole animals that spread
in every cell of their body and they
function just fine like this molecule
has been around science for you know
years and years and years decades and
it's been used in whole animals whole
animals have this molecule in it and so
it was kind of like funny it was a joke
it was like one of the most ridiculous
thing because they were basically saying
like 40 years of research that's been
done by scientists and animal testing
that's been done by scientist doesn't
matter you have to submit your own you
know approval pre-market approval to get
this done we just you know we kept
selling them and do we kept marketing
them as for brewing and baking and
things like that and they didn't come
after us and they haven't come after us
and I think that's because the FDA
selectively regulates like a lot of
government right they're like what are
the chances of this actually hurting
somebody and do we have anybody who who
could possibly testify against this
person no like this thing you know I've
drank a lot of the glowing beer I drank
it with t-pain you know haha in October
made some with t-pain and we drank sent
like a bunch of people who drank this
it's it's totally good I don't know what
people are worried about yeah and and it
just struck me that I mean you said
earlier you know your mission here is to
get this in the hands of as many people
as possible and eventually because and
and it kind of strikes me a little bit
there's a parallel between you and
someone like the Cody Wilson at defense
distributed who pioneered the 3d gun and
there's a reality of like firearms exist
so might as well get them to the people
and good luck government trying to stop
it and it seems like your attitude here
is kind of like genetic engineering is
here it's it's a reality and who do we
want to be in control of that power is
that about right exactly
no that's the thing it's like not only
is my company you know trying to educate
people and stuff like that but what it's
trying to do is
if regulation actually happens right
like if you look at guns in the US and
there's more guns than people who live
in the US like a buyback is not gonna
work
you can't go door to door either like it
just not only cost too much time and
money but like people it it would be
crazy there would be all-out war and you
can imagine the same thing having with
genetic engineering if the government
comes and says the stuff is regulated
I hope it's at a place where so many
people have this technology in their
homes that it's just unfeasible yeah
it's just like well good luck trying to
regulate it because everybody already
has a genetic engineering lab in their
home what are you like it's so hard to
track and trace and be you know there's
there's no you know with firearms they
have all these things it's just like
it's too late and I think you should
stop thinking about how do we control
this the government should stop thinking
about how do we control this and instead
they be thinking about how do we use
this technology to help the most amount
of people like bioethicists investor
timing there's so many people dying
right now and suffering right now those
are the people that you should be scared
for the people who aren't getting help
now don't be scared for the people who
are going to inject themselves with some
DNA and you know might get a sore arm
for a day like those people are gonna be
fine yeah he's scared for the terminally
ill people who are dying right now
yeah and the one of the kind of
positives to come out of the Trump
administration is passing this federal
right to try law which allows people to
easier access to experimental treatments
people who are terminally ill and so
this is kind of taking right to try a
step further which is interesting but
we're coming to the end here and I want
to just get through some of the
questions because people have been
asking some good questions so we'll do a
kind of fast let's see a radical bear
question radical bear yes that great
question before how does biohacking move
from a mature world to a world like we
have with
Computers where an average person is
programming our costs of a full lab a
big bottleneck no cost a bit like we
sell labs for our company for under
$2,000 so that's not necessarily the
bottleneck and you could get it you know
way cheaper if you scavenged ebay and
got parts and stuff yourself it's not
the bottleneck I think the bottleneck is
just education community resources right
like tutorials and things like that I
think it just needs to people to
contribute in the there's a lot of
people who normally had this knowledge
PhD scientists and academics they think
it's the worst thing in the world to
tell people how to do this stuff so the
very few people who had the knowledge a
priori who are willing to provide the
knowledge now so it's just building up
that you know base level of knowledge
that people can just go to and be like I
want a tutorial on how to edit a rabbit
using CRISPR
there's a step-by-step guide exactly
where you order stuff from and exactly
how you do it and there isn't that right
now and there here's another one I just
lost it okay hello I'm a sim I'm I'm
sorry I am Pro this but do you think
there needs to be some regulations in
regards to human slavery child abuse etc
some people might make beings just to be
abused there needs to be some regulation
well that that seems well that's the
point yeah that's kind of like we
already banned slavery but I don't know
if you have anything to add to that yeah
no it was like here's the thing is like
you look at cars right and people will
start driving in cars and people got in
car accidents and they're like oh [ __ ]
you know what we should do is you put in
some stop signs and some guardrails and
stoplights and I know there's probably
some you know super libertarians out
there who are like stop signs are just a
government way to control us you know
like stop signs and guardrails are kind
of good right like it's a pencil let's
say on a privatized road or not to be
honest yeah yeah but I mean you know a
guardrail like nobody
it's hard to like find a thing wrong
with a guardrail and you can imagine
that like we can put guard rails in
place for some of these technologies I
don't exactly know how yet but I think
it's definitely possible to put in these
guardrails to put in these stoplights
that don't infringe necessarily on
people's rights they just make it safer
for everybody so people aren't like
accidentally crashing into each other
well maybe what this person is getting
at is is there some way that for
instance a military could kind of
engineer a super soldier you know
somebody that has no fear and no are you
know I don't know how much of this can
is that nobody really knows how much of
this is genetically determined but just
kind of really turning up the attributes
that make somebody a good soldier and
then this person almost becomes a
proprietary creation of the government
our that might be along the lines of
what this person is worrying about is
scenarios where governments or
corporations or other organizations are
kind of like tweaking things for their
own their own gain oh I'm sure I'm sure
people the thing is I can already create
all other animals that are super ripped
and jacked right I mean I could tell you
the mutations right now that you need to
make or even to change their appease you
need to give yourself self stuff I mean
EPO is already used by people it's put
in their body you could do EPO gene
therapy to increase your endurance right
you could do full of statin to increase
your musculature they've done this in
every animal follow statin you could do
a lot of different modifications to
where you'd be a very good athlete have
lots of endurance and I'm sure you could
find some way to inhibit fear or
knockout things like that it's not
unreasonable to think this stuff can
happen how do we stop it from happening
I don't know like I don't the thing is I
think the problem with technology is we
always try to
why the the the world of right now and
the thinking of now to what is it's
going to be like in the future and we
have no idea what the regulatory
structure is going to be what the in you
know commercial nature of this stuff
what the industrial nature of this stuff
is going to be like how it's gonna be
perceived by society in the future it
might that people don't mind it might be
something that people hate you know who
knows and so let's wrap up with just
your prognostications for the next five
to ten years what do you think is like
what are we in store for you know I
thought if you were to ask me yeah
before the sky genetically engineered
embryos
when genetically modified em goes was
gonna happen I probably would have said
five or ten years from now and it
happened you know this year if you were
to ask me when's the you know time
somebody's gonna try to genetically
modify themselves experimentally after I
had tried I would have said another year
or two and it happened right after like
within two months or something I think
this stuff is moving so fast and it's
it's really exciting and I think that's
just gonna lead to a lot of positive
benefits for us I think the big thing
we're gonna probably see is if the u.s.
does ban this stuff there are a lot of
places and within close proximity like
Saint Lucia Saint Kitts Haiti Dominican
Republic that don't have an FDA that
don't have any form of medical
regulation and it wouldn't be hard for
somebody to go set up there and have
people fly over and do this type of
stuff help people and maybe also modify
them so there I have enhancements okay
well if you want to know more about this
stuff go to the - Odin dot-com that's
Josiah's website you can get yourself a
CRISPR kit and
learn to do this yourself I'll put up a
shot of a there tree frog kit which
allows you to I guess you can actually
make this little frog glow it doesn't
actually make them grow it's actually a
it takes the human gene i gia certs it
into it so igf-1 it's primarily
expressed during puberty moans that
makes human bigger and stronger or
muscular right so it makes the frog
bigger makes them grow big all right
well we all want a future with a huge
tree frogs everywhere so yeah so yet
check out josiah at the odin calm thank
you very much for joining us josiah i'm
gonna yeah i love work you guys do i
especially use that i love all the work
you do it's awesome man thanks man I
appreciate it and I'm gonna just talk to
the audience a little bit and let you
and first of all thank you everyone who
tuned in to the live stream this was an
first time for me like I said and was
there's a learning curve here so
apologies for any technical difficulties
but we will get better and I hope I
personally will get better and as I
mentioned it's not gonna be if we
continue doing this in the new year it's
not going to be only me in the hot seat
so we're we're open to suggestions if
there are people you'd like us to see
you'd like to see interviewed on here or
topics feel free to you know leave those
in the comments section or I just put up
up sorry that's not speaking of
technical difficulties let's see we want
the email okay the emails not up here
but just questions at reason.com if you
email us there you can ask us ask
questions of our next guest who will be
Lenoir skin AZ or you can suggest future
guests and just let us know you know if
you do like this idea and if it's worth
continuing or not
I think the the forum is interesting
just because it allows the kind of free
air flowing conversation people through
in interesting questions that took us in
to new places that I wouldn't have taken
us so I think it's a it's a fun thing to
try so tomorrow we'll be back here same
time 7:00 p.m. Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific
talking to Leonor scan Daisy who is
known as one time known as America's
worst mom for letting her seven-year-old
ride home by himself on the New York
subway and then she started the
free-range parents project and she's now
partnered with social psychologist
Jonathan hight and started something
called let grow which is all about
raising free and independent children in
a society that encourages the opposite I
would say so that should be interesting
and then just a preview on Wednesday
we'll be talking with Rick Doblin who
founded the group Maps which is the
premier psychedelic science research
organization and that we're going to
talk about the latest developments in
psychedelic science and also the
legalization of psychedelics some
interesting stuff is bubbling up there
and then Thursday I'm going to be
talking with Christian O'Brien of the
YouTube channel 1791
el which is a young conservatory entire
political channel and we're gonna be
talking about the future of the right
with him because he is part of that and
then on Friday I'm gonna bring a deter
Nick Gillespie editor at recent
editor-at-large Nicholas be on the
stream and we're gonna touch again on a
topic we touched before which is
post-modernism we made a video together
about that and got a lot of interesting
reactions so we want to respond to the
reaction so you can actually start now
emailing me at questions that
centcom any questions you might have for
Nick and we may or may not have a
special guest on that episode as well so
we've got some interesting stuff coming
up remember to subscribe and press the
notifications button to know when we go
live and thank you once again for tuning
in
this was fun bye
[Music]